[Music]
and could have been prevented news
submitted by Julia not Hulya okay which
one is it
what's a for Julia like Julia you know
I'm both I'm I'm both I'm cool with all
three okay anyway I meant that this
person was named Julia not you yeah
that's not nice
yeah stop drinking dildos test results
show that former NFL star Aaron
Hernandez did have brain disease yes
yeah he killed a couple you killed
somebody in a nightclub I think I don't
know anything about this
you don't Aaron Hernandez in the last
story is kind of old right yeah so he
was a New England Patriot try the
Hilaire that's what that was this
position yeah so Thomas Warner
so he committed suicide in his prison
cell back in April okay are you guys
doing
children yeah sure
all right so you committed suicide he
was 27 years old he had a daughter
um best fan didn't commit suicide he was
serving a life sentence for a murder of
a semi-pro football player named Odin
Lloyd so here you shot him back in 2013
in April of 2015 he was convicted of
first-degree murder while he was in
prison he was charged with another
murder
a double murder by drive-by shooting and
so and then he ended up hanging himself
in prison Wow
so after his death they did an autopsy
and they found that that he had a very
severe form of CTE which is chronic
traumatic encephalopathy love what that
mean it's pretty much a brain disease
that causes dementia and suicidal
thoughts and it's also it's been linked
to head clash
head trauma concussions but what
happened in junior say Amen God rest his
soul this it's a buildup of tau protein
in parts of the brain so that so from
him doing the footballs the response of
head trauma
yes proteins banging his head on a head
footballs yeah
and so this affects normal brain
functioning and then it causes
aggression explosiveness impulsivity hey
maybe that's what I got no it also
causes depression memory loss and other
cognitive changes so look so who's the
head why do you know that always looks
that said why do you would you want some
sort of brain disease no but it just
sounds like me
it doesn't like your see what if I got
that it's Beulah wait do you have
suicidal thoughts no then is not you did
you blame I want to live huh did you
play ball at all okay it's not you oh I
play I played flag football that couch
junior high absolutely not you don't get
touched and when they grab your
waistband this is very traumatic that's
true actually I got touch with my butt
one time my nan today oh yeah I had that
where we played two-hand touch they
gained state a little [ __ ] Fleck hey
hey that's my butt man yeah yeah so they
found that for Aaron's brain he had a
the most like one of the most severe
forms of CT ever detected in someone in
his age he had stage three out of four
stages so um got in all that trouble
exactly do you shot those people not
Aaron Hernandez but if you really boil
it down in football really the NFL
killed so many people if you really try
to like do that's crazy how dizzy like a
mental like physiological trauma can
turn you into a killer yeah exactly
it's crazy do boxers get that too or is
that something else it seems that it's
mainly football players okay
so Boston University is conducting a
major investigation into CTE and
football and it's funded by the National
Institutes of Health and it's been
analyzing hundreds of former players and
in one of the reports
it showed that 110 out of the 111
player's brains that they studied had
signs of CTE Falls like the only sport I
probably would have that type of play
yeah so much research on head trauma and
all kinds of stuff is just really a
horrible sport Aaron Hernandez was also
heavily gang involved and related yes
like all his friends were gang members
like it was a lot of that going on -
it's not I mean I'm just saying I don't
it was already kind of aggressive or
reckless well that's his life that's his
world yeah because if you're in the gang
world you know
it's a prerequisite to shoot somebody up
or like it's a part of the it's a part
of the lifestyle you know I'm just
saying what would a CTE per like someone
who's afflicted with CTE who say it's
not it from that environment or from
that world would they would it be the
same result I don't know or they could
beat their life right sure yeah that's
true normal stuff like yeah wife-beating
or like brother beating or simply yeah
come out of holic and then hang
themselves these players these former
players I had CTE they commit suicide
like this so it's not just you that's
what that's what happened here yeah
junior cell cell yeah Dave Duerson and
Andrea water yeah that's crazy how
something can make you become suicidal
by a headache like a head injury like
you just your computer just kind of
short-circuits or some protein I don't I
don't know what the reason protein can
make you want to commit suicide
because it probably blocks like certain
chemical imbalances oh so you're not
getting the serotonin or dopamine to
balance the happy juices yeah they did
this study I'm not too sure on it but I
think like by the time football players
are in d1 like 90 percent of them
already have this just from playing
through high school and then a little
College so before they even get into and
I thought I already really [ __ ] up and
they have like their contracts aren't as
good as like baseball and basketball
players they suck ass actually yeah as
soon as you're injured they don't take
care of you afterwards you're just gone
yeah well the tough sport it's really
tough you got really loved the sport
yeah Boston University they were saying
that like they released new research and
they showed that football players who
start practicing tackle football from at
least the age of 12 have impaired
emotions and behaviors later on later in
life so yeah I wonder how much of it too
is like you know later in life you don't
have a purpose anymore you don't play no
football like once the sports over for
you it gets worse that it's going to get
more sad plus you know the brain trauma
you're not in the public eye Aaron
Hernandez
this is his brain that's true like all
the build-up of the protein which I
can't point out and tell you what it is
cuz I you know you know like a lot of
athletes after basketball they go off
into doing business and like creating a
brand for themselves and figuring out a
way to stay relevant after the
retirement and same with like baseball
and all that but like I don't really
hear that from football like their
career after their career yeah I think
just recovering the rest of your life
look John Elway just kicked ass with
that oh sure but he's also a quarterback
yeah that's true oh he doesn't yeah
there's a bunch of those guys though
like I know like a [ __ ] LaDainian
Tomlinson is doing a bunch of stuff how
does a bunch of guys maybe it's just not
a household name oh and also it's harder
for them because they spend most of
their time playing with the helmets of
their unidentified that's true so a lot
of light so it's hard to become like a
star star not the individual we don't
even know who it is I was in an elevator
with basketball you see their face so
that's like Michael Jordan's face is
brand and over and over Kobe Bryant's
Brennan over and over like half of these
guys like you hear the name like John
Elway but if you saw him on the street
like wait who is that I don't know
we would know lyy because a little so
much saturation from commercial and [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah certain people click
quarterbacks whatever like the just
running back to guys out of the team
yield you'll know who they are but you
don't know all that's when all these
cats are always like hi I'm Peyton
Manning or whatever you have to do that
oh that makes sense
yeah the word as Michael Jordan really
doesn't ever have to do that everybody
could be in a suit and you could
recognize them yeah I was in an elevator
with Superbowl champion former New York
giant Brandon Jacobs and he had to tell
me that he was Brandon Jacobs and and I
had him on my fantasy team that year
[ __ ] no no idea no idea and I'm a fan of
sport I generally know what a lot of
players look like but now I know no
chance on that's why all those athletes
they always do commercials with like
half their football get up yeah but
whatever they have to wear as a bowl
yeah yes and in their vacuum Drew Brees
yeah eat a Subway sandwich you [ __ ] yeah
it's you know King I didn't know that
the happier times times and this is his
family's lawyer his fiancee and now
they're suing the NFL on behalf of you
know this lawyers that's not generally
sue that I thought you chose to play
well the reason why they're suing is
because they're claiming that the NFL
and the Patriots were well aware of his
life threatening disease and somehow
it's their fault well there's the others
there's been some I guess they're the
x-bow days about how the NFL charges I
hide CTE store they're also saying here
that the NFL cut ties with that study
with Burt a Boston University tailgate
to tell the truth [ __ ] Will Smith
movie they made a movie oh yes about
that [ __ ] yeah what's a bullet I think
it's pretty obvious that you're the
person here only person here that watch
it's the pop yeah yeah that's true yeah
so they cut size of the study in July
and
rumors of a bitter feud between the
league and the lead researcher and then
they're saying that the NFL saw this
doctor as a as critical of football and
so that's why we cut ties with them the
last football game I watched see it's
just like all the big tobacco [ __ ] it's
like you are anti cigarette sir I don't
wanna hear it no it's gonna mess up my
[ __ ] business that's yeah once the
results are in like 90% of people who
are associated with whatever you're
doing they're gonna die it's like of
course you got to find a reason to hide
that's I mean what's gonna happen is
this is gonna change the sport
completely and then it's gonna make it
less entertaining and if we're gonna say
remember the good old days when people
used to play like football it is gonna
just completely change well they're dirt
I'm kind of getting tag-teamed on this
[ __ ] - cuz they're [ __ ] themselves
with all this like taking an e [ __ ]
right now oh yeah as far as America like
the people who actually watch football
are not [ __ ] watching cuz of this you
know because it's just divided it's just
they want to watch sports and yeah they
want to turn their brain off and watch
some sports they don't want to like hear
a bunch of political issues or whatever
no matter what your stand on the
spectrum people don't want to do it
usually so it's like you know what's
gonna disappear slowly disappear I think
I think so man I mean I don't like it
but I think that that's what'll happen
yeah I know I'm over mind that like do
whatever you want protest whatever the
[ __ ] you want burn an American flag if
you want but people don't have to watch
it yeah if they don't want to yeah so
that's probably what's gonna happen I
think cuz I still watch it but I think a
lot of people are turned off yeah just
for now I mean it all died down I
somehow saw like lady football but it
was like just girls in bikini but she
was there going full-on football I used
to do that lingerie football league
lingerie football yeah they were these
tiny little shorter they're like
bodybuilder women but their point
they're like tackle football hardcore
and I'm like
this is very sexual but at the same time
it's football what's going on
footballs are already sexuals Holden
think about that a guy bent over it
throws in the ballgame and they do this
[ __ ] where it's like you know it's like
he grabs the like he touches up in the
upper nut area like this [ __ ] like to
let him know that he's like he's ready
to take the ball it's like John Goodman
tap them on the back that baseball no
they do Diddy but slapping the middle
ear for all sports yeah every spot but
ice-skating I wish they did for
ice-skating yeah
hey Raul guys I hope you guys enjoy the
video please remember to give us a big
thumbs up and a like like like and also
when you guys sign on YouTube make sure
just kidding news is the first thing you
watch every single day because we post
videos every day ok for more videos
[Music]